the bismillah alhamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with you now let me
tell you something you can't buy a
six-pack of peace peace is something
that money cannot buy peace is something
you have purpose in life when you know
why you've been created and this way of
life gives you every single answer to
all your questions why you've been
created where you're going when you die
and this is what the D show is all about
delivering the message of purpose of
life and talking to people who are
living the purpose of life doing good
not only for themselves for the
community but for all of mankind and the
D shows here to help serve and protect
protect you against evil and serve you
so you can help get the message so you
can live a fruitful life my next guest
is doing something great he's a
president now I'm not talking about
President Obama I'm talking about a
president of an organization as doing
some wonderful work and we're gonna meet
him it's a surprise I'm gonna tell you
his name when he comes out don't move
we'll be right back with this exciting
show here on the Deen show be right back
this is the things the thing
welcome back to the Dean show I'm gonna
be talking a little bit slower than
usual we have the president of the
global deaf Muslims and the vice
president so I said look not President
Obama but somebody who's dear to us
who's our brother your brother in in in
humanity my brother in faith Salaam
alaikum so we're going to learn
something through the show we're going
to learn to be grateful and thankful for
all the blessings that we have so and
we're gonna learn some sign language
hamdulillah so I'm gonna start off with
a couple of things peace be with you how
do you say that peace be with you I said
I will ache
show me show the audience how do you say
it go a little bit slower go slow peace
be with you
peace be with you yes do it other get
that shot again from both of them
go ahead peace be with you
thank you for making time to be on the
Deen show your your the president vice
president of the global deaf Muslims we
want to talk to you a little bit tell us
a little bit about your organization
what you do your the organization itself
the global deaf Muslim this is an
American organization here also we have
Canada involved to try to educate Islam
in terms of sign language for the Deaf
because we have about maybe half
the death you know half-a-million about
to the death were located in in America
don't don't have the access to Islamic
knowledge and you know the concept is
not being taught all of these children
you know being neglected away from that
information so hamdullah we're the only
organization here to try to be able to
educate the deaf children also they
don't so what we're gonna do here we're
gonna deliver the message of all the
messages of guys it's a very unique show
and hamdulillah how do you say how do
you say all praise to the creator of the
heavens and earth come do the lobby said
I'm doing there how do you do it um-hum
dalila say right now hamdulillah so how
many did it love all the blessings of
the crater's given us we're gonna you
can you help me
deliver the message of Islam to those
who can't hear inshallah let's start off
with this word Islam let's define what
Islam means Islam is a simple word that
means submission having a relationship
by submitting yourself to the one who
created you the one God Islam here with
teach yes there's only one God and no
other God so Popham happen is he's the
messenger to deliver the message and
revelation of the Quran that's what we
intend to do a very different community
the child also trying to educate them
but the five pillars of Islam and you
know as we know the first one is mister
she had her and how to pray five times
the cat and you know the Madonna and
inshallah has that very end to Mecca
let's talk about the pure monotheism for
a second pure just only worshiping God
one God just one how do you say one God
just one God like do it let me see let
me see one that's it one that's it we
just we don't worship Jesus we don't
worship Muhammad we don't worship the
Sun we don't worship the moon not a
monkey not an elephant not a man not a
woman just God
that's Islam just one God and as soon as
you make a holy ghost into God or you
make Jesus into God you give anyone
divinity next to God you've set up a
partner with God and that crushes the
pure monotheism it's only one God so go
ahead and and expound on this I want you
to expound on this for those people who
let's say they don't know the purpose of
life and we're trying to explain to them
the purpose of life have you had
Encounters of doing Dawa inviting people
to purpose what do you what how do you
start off a conversation in sign
language so often what we do we often go
to colleges messages schools you know
any of those local community centers
what we do is we provide community
service we always teach about inshallah
that look the one god only worship only
know they left all the images idolatry
and all of these things and reflect on
pure monotheism for loss of heart Atta
you know even if you're deaf you know
blind or for whatever reason that you
are neglected away from pursuing those
kind of things but you always know that
the last part the challah is flexible
with us this we're here to worship and
only worship the Creator so we're here
to also educate the deaf people to try
to understand different sign language
how we can connect with each other how
we will share that same boundary you
know when you have a human person you
know they speak and you can you can
share that relationship but when they're
deaf we're that's a boundary we have so
we rely on the sign language to try to
teach that few month ism as others
Lenten teaching let's talk about
relationship the loving relationship
with the loving God Allah the Creator is
the most loving the most kind and he we
dial up to him direct five times a day
when he explains the importance of
connecting with God through the Salah
the prayer how does he like to explain
it the second pillar of Islam
cut yeah it's probably five times a day
just our way to develop a relationship
with allah allah subhanaw taala through
players and to maintain our
communication to ask forgiveness as for
you know have have mercy forgiveness for
others you know and to be humble and and
to do the best deeds that we can do and
hopefully inshallah to repeat them and
to learn from my mistakes and always ask
for forgiveness donor heart you know the
Quran clearly tiller states our law is
very merciful you know the you know each
other since that you may do a lot of
parent eyelids much further we our
duties to ask and this is this this
method of asking is for us to maintain
relationship with Allah to through
prayer who do I tell what was it about
Islam about this way that all the
prophets lived Jesus lived Islam Moses
Abraham Noah they all lived Islam they
all submitted not to any saint not to a
messenger not to themselves but they
submitted to God what was it about this
way of life that fascinated you and
motivated you to do what you're doing
now the Prophet Muhammad annual profit
you know Prophet Abraham and no and all
of them yes they're all Muslim why
because they all believe in one God when
they come to delivered all the same
message which is to worship only one God
Jesus himself said the same thing all to
deliver one message so our deaf
community should understand that because
there have been difficult to understand
the concept is of I thought Jesus only
related to me no Christianity how does
it relate them to Islam so here we have
to educate them you know we're not here
to commit partnership with with the loss
of Hannah Tyler is only one monotheism
and this is what we're trying to do to
try to teach the death and how to
maintain the relationship with us each
other so the message is very you know
it's emphasized and we've tried to make
that clear to the deaf audience and
we're gonna take a break and we'll be
back with more inshallah how do you how
do you say insha'Allah God willing
Charla
listen charm inshallah God willing we'll
be right back
do you think these things are going to
bring you happiness you know why you
keep going back to the club and you keep
going back to these desires because you
never find satisfaction it's going to
end up causing you if it hasn't already
a lot of pain what we are offering in
Islam what we have found in Islam for
ourselves
is a means by which our hearts aren't
pleased they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
those who do I am Not Afraid I am not
afraid to stand alone if you live by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if you live by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone if a box by
my side I am Not Afraid
back here on the DS show with the
president I said we're not here with
President Obama but we're here with our
brother from the global deaf Muslims and
the vice president and they're doing
some wonderful work and we should be
grateful and thankful for all the
blessings that we have and we're trying
to deliver this message a purpose of
life to all the people that don't have
the blessing of hearing so how do you
feel when people look at you you look so
buoyant happy but when some people
they're having so many blessings and
they take these things for granted what
do you like to tell people that are
falling into despair but if they just
look a little bit and count the
blessings of hearing a sight and all the
things that they have from Allah maybe
this will cheer them up what do you like
to tell them now
I always thank a lot of parents out of
for the day and and you know you know as
I was going out you know being born deaf
did not change who I am you know it's
some language here's a method of
communication just to you know the blind
is given different way of communication
everyone's giving different way of
communication but all will have the same
relationship with the last parent Allah
which is you know to make certain
adjustments and how we can communicate
with our Creator me being deaf doesn't
why should I be depressed you know I'm
at least I'm giving a life here to live
and you know there's million other
people here that who are living some of
them you know they have have the same
gift yet you know but some don't you
know inshallah don't have you know arms
or legs or whatever you know everyone
here is given distinct reason and
distinct purpose the most important
thing is here is use our building how to
communicate with Allah subhana Thailand
we should be thankful even though is
that you know a lot upon Allah takes
away something but gives you something
you know this is how this is how I feel
and lived with my life like that if you
weren't if you were able to hear maybe
you wouldn't be doing this wonderful
work and getting all these wonderful
rewards so this is a great blessing how
many people are you able to influence to
help because of the situation you're in
this beautiful situation now because you
can reach out to so many people through
your organization it's a wonderful gift
is it look at that
so now we have money hearing and hearing
people you see they have many
opportunities very many opportunities
deaf you know if you go for example to
any message it you know the hot buzz
none of them are you know be interpreted
and then how can we educate the deaf
today you know and what the purpose of
of what the footpads are about you know
we can't learn them and many families
are you know holding away their children
you know even if they're left with
limiting them access to its land you
know even if for them maybe nine years
old you know soon as then we can always
hear I don't hear it but I'll just go
ahead and pray and you know I lose it I
lose everything they're doing the
footpath
so the Deaf learn primarily based on
visual visual knowledge so this is our
advantage we're here to try to show that
kind of Joe you know how to read the
Quran ha ha you know all of these things
to be able to translate it for the deaf
community and this is the opportunity
that we're trying to make and create for
them we know that when someone comes to
that realization that look I'm gonna die
I'm gonna be in the grave and I'm gonna
have to leave everything behind all the
money all the material things it's all
staying I'm going and it's either
Hellfire or paradise so now I want to
live according to how my Creator wants
me to live why he created me that's the
life I want to fulfill so I can plead my
Creator before I meet my Creator so now
the person starts to investigate and
they find out that Islam is definitely
from the Creator it provides all the
evidence that a person needs to be full
of conviction that this is the truth
it's not blind faith now someone wants
to take the first step and acknowledge
what's in their very nature that there's
only one God nothing worthy of worship
except the one creator and Mohammed is
the final Messenger of God accepting
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
preceding messengers they take the
testimony the Shahada
have you had people
except the Shahada
accept Islam yeah we've had them tell us
tell us tell us a story or tell us
something that you've encountered when
someone is accepted Islam and how you
guide them through it using sign
language so I would say we'll go ahead
with one you know we've worked on
himself one month ago he's he's and he
was a death he come in from Maryland
he'd been travelling to different
countries to see how Islam you know is
related to to personal life and and how
is it different from here United States
according to other country but oh but
he's been trying to you know as soon as
been visibly been contacting me and how
how to do that how we how I can be of
guidance to him when that person came in
you know to Virginia started to learn
sign and started to read the Quran and
said you know starts to believe in one
God and Muhammad is the final messenger
I've had many many stories but I've had
someone from colleges name is Charles
you know and he took the thinking to
2007 since he's been with me for Muslim
took the Shahada that that year you know
he's trying to now to to embrace this
religion trying to read the Quran as
much as he can you know you know some
people will look at him if he's a Muslim
or not but he's truly devoted to reading
the Quran try to understand this is the
effort that you know the data that we're
trying to give to try to understand the
clear it up to this day so you know
there's money money just now converting
but you but this is the negative but we
don't have the materials to give them
you know you know the access compared to
a hearing person directly you have
spoken languages you have DVDs you have
all of these things that are available
but to the death what can we do how can
we give them so so it's difficult but
you know but we're doing everything I
can and Charlotte a lot of
to to come into Islam and global deaf
Muslim is here to establish that reasons
and and and it's good becoming better in
childhood we have the verbatim word of
God the Quran it's tamper free tamper
proof it's not edited by man to suit the
times it's been preserved it's a living
miracle for anyone who takes a look
sincerely they will see that the Quran
is from the Creator it's in the original
language the Arabic they're memorized by
millions talks about phenomenons
prophecies everything is in this book
how can someone who is deaf now they can
obviously they can read right so how is
it something different for someone who's
who can't hear to pick up the the Quran
how could they get access is it harder
for them to be able to read the Quran
obviously they're not they're not blind
but it is is it is it is it any more
difficult for someone who can't hear to
read the Quran yeah it's not what you
see I'm educated I went to college you
know a vice president is the same our
board is the same all of us had the
opportunity to go to to attain his
education and we're using our education
to teach them so if we feel if you look
at the you know the first chapter so I
thought I have you know most of the time
in the first ayah you see in the name of
in the name of God but this this kind of
thing usually it's very it's very
difficult to explain but we have to
explain the concept we're using our
expressions using you using our
understanding and try to use specific
sign language for them to be able to to
understand this because most of them
pick up the Quran and read and it's
difficult for them
I see I'm really here to provide classes
also provide classes to give them that
concept you know ayah by aya not really
either I am NOT the concept because you
know as they read they they lose the
meaning exactly yeah so so that might be
her to do you know in the you know the
Quran is in Arabic to be able to
translate in English there's so many
different translations you know
call them exactly they found out the
concept of what the Arabic tries little
Asian is trying to say but we're doing
the same to try to give that concept
similar in sign language that's so
important and you guys are doing that
work so we're going to take a break and
we'll be right back two inch inshallah
again I do it again
inshallah inshallah to continue more
here on the Deen show with our special
guests right back
iserlohn Dios
solo yeah na seuk lesson I would go to
my room lock the door go straight and
class thank God you know me better than
myself show me the right way and I will
not look to how we leave everything
behind a lot of that greater and we
create everything it gives intelligence
to people Mohammed as well as the Rasmus
Anderson from God
back here on the DS show with our
special guests from the global deaf
Muslims we're almost out of time let's
learn some common phrases in sign
language real easy that the people can
go home we learned that hamdulillah
how do you do it again alhamdulillah
praise in the crater all thanks is to
God I'm duelin alhamdulillah everybody
do it hamdulillah al hamdulillah and
handle it
let's go el ha al hamdulillah al
hamdulillah
oh it's Mila bismillah that means in the
name of God bismillah we always start
the show and we say bismillah in the
name of God the Creator yes how do you
say worship the Creator not his creation
and also the long one but worship the
creator not his creation
that's worship the Creator not his
creation creation worship creator not
his creation okay how do you say how are
you how are you how are you you how do
you say I love you I love you
how do you say I love God I love God I
love God how do you say how do you how
do you say what are some other common
common things expressions through sign
language that are that are important do
you think it's lamb how do you say it's
loud
this is this land Islam submission to
one God it's lamb submission to one God
it's life Muslim Muslim it's lamb much
less lamb what if someone says look you
know how do you tell her has anybody I
mean you know there's a lot of
Islamophobia hysteria out there you know
people trying to make Islam like you
know it's the other it's from outer
space and these guys are coming to you
know bring havoc on the earth so have
you dealt with anyone that now looks at
Islam and Muslims in a bad light how do
you explain to get this stereotype you
know this this false persona out of
people's mind what do you like to tell
them oh yeah observe that a lot of time
in college man in college years they're
my own roommates we're not Muslim but
there are those from Malaysia we were
roommates and really know it's gone
everyday as soon as you know 9/11 struck
can happen the whole shift of Islam
changed and and it was my duty you know
to explain you know this small group you
know it's this other that what we call
extra me do you know the Commission who
are destroying their name is Lena yeah
Islam here's to us to give peace and
we're here to you know abide by the
Quran and and what happened in that that
time it's completely different from what
what you know what a lost panel tells us
to do and as a Muslim we should live by
the
earn as much better as we can and we
have here to teach our deaf community to
you know so when they look in the City
TV this is the visual meter that they're
looking for you know they can they can
become very washed and they can become
that kind of you know information that
perceives out the outside world not to
be according story slam but this is
there is no Islamophobia and we are here
to change all of that also in trying to
translate also the message in ASL from
the Quran that we've nothing to do with
honor
organization you know this never had
been attained before but in in terms of
Islamophobia during the college you know
the West it's funny how the Deaf they
know the Bible but the Quran you know
that they have all these resources
available for them but on it's not there
so you can perceive the information to
be wrong and become you know it's the
slammer for if you know by by looking at
what the media is trying to show but we
are here to educate them to worship only
the our Creator not to worship the
prophets not users not not any of those
messengers are Langstrom some of it but
just just our Creator and we're here to
try to do that what's so special if you
had to tell someone in sign language
what's so special about the Quran I know
this can be a topic in itself but just
say sure what's so special about this
car and the car itself is the miracle of
miracles this is our revelation you know
and and there's none other like it you
know this is I will live in some this is
what everyday in life you know and all
the questions all all the questions you
have in life you know pertaining to to
to usually to anything so anything that
you can think of the answers in the
Quran you know we here don't allow other
people that we don't worship as Muhammad
but Allah only subhanaw taala
he's the one who's giving us you know
this life and everything is subjected
inside the Quran and the way of life and
how we approach people how we forgive
people or all of these things and first
for safety and peace is with all in the
Quran this is that this is our best you
know this this is our best specialty
here that we have in the car and also to
love myself also to love you
you know you know even if you call me
I'll forgive you this all these messages
are are in the Quran this is the beauty
of it you know and we are here as a
brothers and sisters we should be one
Omer to adhere to that masha'Allah
tell us how people can get a hold of
your organization get a hold of you
through your organization the name of
the organization your website
localization name is global deaf Muslim
the website is G Global GL obal deaf DEA
F Muslim mus aalayam dot org o RG and
this is the only website that we have in
America you know so far you know others
many many different organizations that
you see but all of them are working in
the spoken language but alhamdulillah we
are the only organization that are
included in sign language so as you can
see our community is very tight together
so we're trying to pursue and explain
explain what we're trying to do but you
know we have a website you can do we can
go to so like like for example one of
our project that next year we're trying
to promote 40 deaf people to inshallah
go to Omaha we're trying to promote that
kind of project you know to bring the
Deaf together and educate them as much
as we can you know maybe want women 1 1
2 2 3 years but probably inshallah maybe
the Deaf will understand what Islam is
about so right now organizations are set
up to the Muslim deaf Development Center
for example in Ghana which want to set
one up in Ghana in Africa there's about
there's so many deaf Muslims don't you
know don't have that kind of access and
they're being oppressed then you know
and the informations being neglected so
we we're not only here to focus in
America about the world because all of
us will share the same thing you know
today people come you know in religion
try to come and promote you know try to
convince us and push as much as they can
but but what we're doing is we're
teaching is you know to try to make them
understand what they say right or not
you know a quote and according to the
Quran we often are in contact with
scholar
you know we're making DVD electronic
material all of these things the global
deaf Muslim we are doing so so this is
why we have a whole you know material so
we can interchange that kind of
information and this is on our website
office so at global deaf Muslim comm you
have video or org you have videos to
educate deaf people on Islam and the
purpose of life it's there yes this is a
new organization but now we were created
in that in 2009 we had that opportunity
so right now our classes are going to be
recorded also and will be projected on
on the website we will start showing
that know some work in progress but
inshallah with your help we can be able
to do that beautiful let's go ahead and
one last time let the people know that
there's only one guy worship him alone
not his creation and Mohammed is the
last and final messenger take it away
say again ten one time says family and
there's only one God worship others no
just one God and the messenger who's the
last messenger of Prophet Mohammed
that's all the time that's all the time
we have thank you very much for being
with us may God Almighty reward you for
the wonderful work that you're doing
both for you thank you
Shakalaka oh yeah thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
appreciate all the wonderful blessings
that you have and you'll see some of the
most wonderful people that we have in
our history who are in the worst
situations but I didn't blame their
situation they made the best out of
their situation and they rose to the
occasion and they rose to the top so
rise to your full potential and the only
way you can do that is by submitting to
the game plan not your game plan but
God's game plan the game plan of the
crater that heavens and earth who
created you who took care you are you in
the womb of your mother who gave you
life and he'll give you death and
the end you'll be in the grave and
you're gonna have to answer for
everything you've done in this life and
at the end it's either hell fire or
paradise and the only way acceptable to
the Creator is submission to his will
now submitting ting to Jesus not
worshiping a holy ghost not worshipping
a monkey an elephant but only
worshipping the Creator and not the
creation and it starts by wanting by
realizing that you're not
self-sufficient you need the air that
you breathe you need the food that you
eat and who's given that to you the
Creator that happens in Earth
so only worship Him and develop yourself
to be the best human being that you can
be having good character good manners
staying away from all the things that
he's told you to stay away from and
doing all the wonderful things that the
crater's told you to to do and that's
the purpose of life obeying God
submitting to God loving God because He
loves you and he's given you everything
so appreciate all these blessings by
obeying him and we hope that you
continue to tune in here to the Deen
show you could pick up the new dunya to
Deen get our DVDs get the purpose of
light bumper sticker and we'll see you
next time here on the Deen show until
then peace be with you